your career took off after Twilight and
you credit your success to the use of
something called vision boards I've
heard of people using vision boards
where they they make a I guess they take
a cardboard board and they put up what
they put up ideas and images of what
they want to accomplish it helps them
see what they're gonna do is that will
help I think it stems from the secret or
some inspirational book yeah and I
finally just had time to make mom
because I was playing host so I didn't
really have time to like make mine at
the event I threw I wanted to talk to
people so yesterday as I was driving up
to Dillon were some racetrack up north
it's two hours up north and I was I was
going up there because the VIPRE gum
ball team were there there were racing
around the track anyways I was doing my
vision board my buddy drove just because
we wanted to race the Vipers on you're
pasting inspirational yeah he's driving
you up to a race yeah and you're in the
backseat pasting your vision board cut
it cut it out the glue stick the windows
some stuffs line anyways we get up there
I'm halfway done with my board and I'm
racing these Vipers and they have this
other track where you can race your car
I drove up with my cop car I'm like I
got to give this baby a shot right so
I'm racing on this track racing a Viper
and I forget that all my vision board
stuffs in the back and I'm like hitting
this turn going 60 and you just boom
boom boom and then glitter I don't I
don't have glitter on glitter on your
vision board
get in touch with my soft steel but
glitters like fly never and you can't
stop it was a race I'm very competitive
yeah but by the time we were done I had
because one of your visions was don't
stop that was your boy just keep going
and then I had protein shake everywhere
and then I hate it you know what I hate
when glitter gets in my protein today
while I'm racing my cop car
that's the worst experience you can have